Zero help you will get money.
>> What the going on? >> What is that? >> Side
quest. >> The cops are here. Why?
>> Whoever still needs to scan that RFID is not not going
to be having a fun time.
>> I mean, and Shuy Shuy caused it as well >> because
he got no tags on his car. So they pulled the van over because
he got no tags and then they saw her.
>> And she sucks dog pe
as shown on the internet. If you search her name, you'll see
a video of her sucking a small little dog's
on video.
>> Let's see. Is he in there? >> Is he in there?
>> Oh my god. Is he in there? Are you in
>> The circles can't.
>> He might be in there,
>> dude. He's in there. >> Dude, you're going to
[__] up your fingers, buddy.
>> Oh, it's a ninja turtle. Wait, I saw it. >> Ninja
turtle. >> It's a [__] >> I thought he
said something else.
>> I am. I'm Mexican. I can say it. >> I was like,
whoa. >> I'm Mexican. I can say it.
>> Stop helping other streamers. >> Wait, I didn't
I didn't see him before. He throw it this one. >> Wait,
he throws this one. Can Mexicans say it? I have no idea. Can
you credit
>> Zero help you get money.
>> What the [__] going on?
>> Side quest.
>> Is he in here? Where is he?
>> Anakin Skywalker.
>> 12 addition problems.
Each addition problem
is attributed to each letter.
Okay. So the for the example the first one 3 + 13
you go to the third letter in the word green
which is E.
And then what letter is 13 letters plus
from E?
and that's the logic. And then you just do that for the whole
thing.
That's all you had to do. It's simple. It's pretty straightforward.
It's not complicated at all. It's very
How would you not How? It's It's very obvious. It's very very
very obvious.
Oh, look who's look who I see at the airport.
Lety coming in late.
She must have just landed or something.
Bro, if if people forget to uninstall this app when this is over,
I get to stalk people.
No, I'm just kidding. I'm going to delete the app afterward.
Well, so far
the so far nobody's even close to figuring it out. >> Right.
Hit it, Dan.
>> No one's even got the correct logic or anything from
what I can tell. You still don't get a ticket back. >> Let's
go back to action, man. Let's see if he's got any logic. >> Harassment
dude hiding behind
the homeless guy before we work in that dirty ahole of yours.
Boy, >> suck my
come say that [__] in my face. >> That homeless
guy. >> Wait, what's the 16th
number in the alphabet and what's two? What's 16 and
>> No. One minus negative. That's not it. These are coordinates
cuz there's a negative in front of the Okay. I don't know. Oh,
at least I'm trying.
>> Nice people.
>> The cops are here. Why?
>> Well, whoever still needs to >> Oh my god.
>> Whoever still needs to scan that RFID is not not going
to be having a fun time. >> Don't walk too fast cuz they're
just
little fighting over there. >> Fighting. Who's
>> Wait, multiple. Oh, they got like >> they got
like four cop cars there. The
>> six, bro. They got six cop cars for >> On it.
Oh, that's got swarm. >> Who? What's going
>> It is completely [__] up.
I can't believe it. I don't know how I'm going to feel I don't
know how I'm ever going to feel better about this or get over
this. I have no idea. I have no trust for anybody
anymore. I don't trust anybody. I don't want to help small streamers
anymore. I don't want to give money to small stream.
Goon and Lav have just dug themselves a very deep hole. Like
I said, you can enjoy your inflated viewer count,
but it is certainly not going to last very long.
There are some bridges that are just not worth burning. and Goon
will forever realize that his wife has just thrown this money.
>> So, I hope it was worth it.
>> There are some bridges that are just not worth burning.
>> DJ or whoever the I don't even remember what his name
was.
>> Or it could have been Zena. That's true. Actually, that
sounds kind of like Zena to be honest. >> Where is your
pit crew?
I mean, Zena is nowhere near Taza, though. But she must have
she could have drove off,
but I feel like she would have streamed it if it was her. She
wouldn't. I mean, I don't think she would do it off stream. She
would want to make some kind of content out of it.
>> Turn the tire straight.
>> They're trying to blame you for uh slashing Todd's tires.
>> I didn't slash anybody's tires. >> I know. They're
trying to blame you on, >> bro. They trying to blame me
on everything and I'm getting sick of the dumb [__]
[__]
Nobody. Why? First of all, of all
>> I would never do no [__] like that to
the [__] I would never [__] try Tazo
like that. >> Losing the boat first.
>> The immediate over an hour.
>> Loitering is the most victimless crime
>> I mean, it's a homeless shelter. They are used to loitering.
>> Every time I drive past this place, there's 20 homeless
people loitering here at all times, 24 hours a day.
>> Oh, it's okay. I'm Jewish. I'm Jewish.
>> Well, we have 14 minutes until the chess is here. So,
>> I'll get a ticket for $1,500 chest. >> They have
14 more minutes until the chest is available. Come on, lady.
>> No, the APD already is aware of the whole entire ordeal.
>> I'm not I'm not pressing, they will make us. You don't
think >> these people are insane, dude. Come on. Calling
the police for
standing around doing nothing is crazy. >> Tell me I gave
out food and water. Like, why they on Bro, you gave all these
pizza. Like, they need to shut the up, >> Oh, true. They
gave pizza. They gave them water. They're helping the homeless
right now. >> You ain't giving out no pizza, [__]
>> They're helping the homeless >> with your fake
ass Junth shirt on. >> Take that Junth shirt off. >> Oh,
no. >> Take that Junth.
>> And also at the end of the day it's it's not really
that big of a deal.
Like whatever. Like
you guys never seen a fight before. Like it happens. Yeah. Like
whatever happens. >> It's really not that big of a deal.
>> Who is that? You can't park there ass. >> Excuse
me. You can't park there. Oh my
>> Keep checking the front. >> Keep going. Keep going,
>> bro. Okay. >> Dropping some tests for you. Go
ahead. Dollar each. Dude's taking a nap in >> In there?
>> Yeah. He's taking a nap on his in his camp. Oh. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. He might know. He's an informant. >> This
is >> That's what I was told. Yeah. We got back in there.
>> He's sleeping on his mattress in here, bro. We >> 100
more of those chests. You can get a
>> bro. You good? >> Oh my god. You've seen the movies
too much, bro. You know all about Get Out. I know. That's why
you got the back. I know you smart camera.
>> Yeah. All right. All right. So, look. Uh >> Where's
he at? He's right there. He's
>> He's probably kissed. >> I know. >> Got
a bunch of random people in there. >> He dropped the chest
on the bum.
>> I got it. Oh my god. This has got to be really bad.
>> this is an intervention. >> The roach.
>> $1 to
Oh my god. All right. Of >> course he got it. >> Anonymous
tip $3.33.
Never forget Ice took Kimmy back after Goona pounded her with
his 9 in. Dude, you are pathetic.
>> Oh, good one. >> No, that's complete.
>> They're just mad that they're losing
>> and they have to go after my girlfriend who is not involved
with this at all.
>> Okay, he married this girl Lav. He makes money off of
his wife's only fans now. So he's like, "Well, I can live off
my wife's only fans, even though they're all leaked online. You
can watch it completely for free, and you don't need to buy her
Only Fans." And she sucks dog
as shown on the internet. If you search her name, you'll see
a video of her sucking a small little dog's
on video.
um he lives off his wife only fans now. So he didn't he felt
like he didn't need me anymore. So he complet he held withheld
him in bringing him to everything. Kimberly
was always like don't bring him. I don't like him. And I was
like well whatever. I think he's funny. So I always brought you
to the events. I always invited you to places and you want to
try and [__] me over.
>> I'm just going to do my two together. I think I can
reach. >> Wait. too much. Which way is yours? >> But
it's okay. You showed me that Kimberly is not the girl for me.
But you also showed me your true character with your wife. So,
I will make sure to make it my mission in life
to now destroy everything that you and Lav have ever
And as for Kimberly, well,
>> I mean, I don't care what she does. >> Oh, my
bad. I just want her to go home and never see me again.
>> You are on Kick's [__] list.
I will make sure that you will never be given any opportunity
ever
as a streamer.
And then all her all all her little
all Goon's little friends, cute bot,
the job Millie,
all these little friends of theirs.
They didn't tell me. No one decided to man up. Everyone's a coward.
It is unbelievable.
But it's okay. These people live in glass houses
and these people are all very very
and and and evil
spiteful people
>> be hanging around on stream.
>> Get that. >> She did nothing, guys.
>> She did nothing. >> Did nothing wrong. That that
clip is AI.
I mean, and Shuy Shuy caused it as well >> because he got
no tags on his car. So, they pulled the van over >> because
he got no tags and then they saw
>> And then once they saw her, it's game >> Bring
my dog.
>> You know, she's
my dog. >> I mean, really, it's her own fault. If you had
a warrant, why you why you hanging around streamers? That's the
worst thing you can do. >> The [__]
Wait, bro.
>> I wonder. I mean, Shu is going to get a massive ticket,
dude. >> Driving around with no plates is like a I don't
even know. Maybeow. >> No, no, no.
>> I don't want him to die.
>> What is What is Shugi doing, bro?
Don't. Don't. No. No. You turn. Put it
>> Where the Okay. I mean, hey, better going off road than
being on the highway. I
Whatever, dude. Off-road is way way
>> He's got a gun. He's got the gun. >> You're not
going to shoot the gun to the car, bro.
>> Yo, no. >> No. No. No. No. No. No.
>> Ice. He's got the gun. You got to tell >> yo,
gun is not allowed, >> bro. Shuy, you got to put the gun,
bro. Put the bro, put the BB gun down, Shuy, this is
At least they're not At least they're not on the road with any
other cars. >> No one's on them. >> You're going
to have to give up. So, >> this is ridiculous.
>> We will share the hits, not the 500
>> and bringing him to everything. Kimberly
was always like, "Don't bring him. I don't like him. And I was
like, well, whatever. I think he's funny. So, I always brought
you to the events. I always invited you to places. And you want
to try and [__] me over.
>> I'm just going to do my two together. I think I can
reach it. >> Wait. I'm going to do my >> Which one
is yours? >> But it's okay. You showed me that Kimberly
is not the girl for me. But you also showed me your true character
with your wife. So, I will make sure to make it my mission in
life to now destroy everything that you and Lav have ever
And as for Kimberly, well,
>> I mean, I don't care what she does. >> Oh, my
bad. >> I just want her to go home and never see me again.
>> Somebody's got a big Obama mask on. >> I don't
have money now.
Come on guys. One at a time guys. Don't make me my phone man.
I'll start miss. Come on guys.
>> Make him hesitant to come back. Maya Gdowski says it's
not going to stop her but that does make her angry. >> I
I feel like this day and age where social media can really make
you or break you. people are feels like. >> Imagine you
see this news article and then you went out to the domain later
that day and you saw the same guy in the news article wearing
a pink bikini
with a selfie stick. Like you see it's like oh you just watched
the news and then all of a sudden later that day you see him
walking around in a pink bikini. >> Age where social media
can really make you or break you. People are feels like going
out of their way to just try to be funny when they're they're
not. They're just disrespectful. >> Austin police say they
have identified a suspect, but they haven't been able to arrest
that person yet. In downtown Austin, Jessica Cha. >> Well,
if they download my app,
if the police download my app, they will see her [__]
location cuz I'm pretty sure it's still showing.
Ice, watch,
>> look at this [__] [__] >> Look
at this ice. Listen, Ice. >> Ice, look. >> Listen,
bro. >> It's bad. >> Both legs, bro.
>> It's horrible, bro. It's >> I felt >> I
fell three times. I fell three times, >> I fell three times.
>> We are getting cut. >> Just a few cuts. Yeah.
I mean, you know, you go through the You go through thorns in
the woods. That's what happens. That ain't That ain't too bad.
>> That ain't too bad. Literal sticker still, bro. Can
you get that out, >> Watch how sharp and sharp and sharp.
>> Oh, I see it. Just be careful. >> I mean, going
through the woods with an
really ain't that >> Michael Jackson ain't good. >> Got
the Michael Jackson curls, bro. >> You going to get some
spiders and [__] in your hair. >> Curl is in
there. It's in there. Oh, it's in there. >> I love community
building. I don't love watching a 4ft 11 maniac random people
in public. Why does that need to be part of the content? >> Well,
I would rather it not be a part of the content. I don't know
why she's doing that. I Oh, I got yanked on the >> Yeah,
she shouldn't do that. That's not
>> The viewer who's the closest to the correct answer,
you know, the closest to the coordinates. All right. 4 in raid.
I don't even know what that means. I don't know who the 4 in
is, but I appreciate
the raid. Uh hopefully that's, you know, it's not your dick size.
Four inches